of ours of the American West but an
ominous trend that's been building for
years is apparent once again this year
one that could threaten the way of life
for the entire region John Blackstone
has the story
springtime is when reservoirs across the
American West should be full this year
as in many years past they are not Lake
Mead and like all big reservoirs in the
Colorado River and these big white
bathtub rings around the marks left as
the water declines there's less water in
the system now than there was 20 and 30
years ago John flack author of water is
for fighting over has spent decades
studying the Colorado River a crucial
source of water in much of the West the
persistence of the drought conditions in
the Colorado River Basin especially is
essentially unprecedented in human
history what is happening a new study
says is not just a drought
it's a mega drought it's a pretty
dramatic term mega drought if they go
back in time 500 years or so there were
these phenomenal droughts in terms of
both severity and in terms of length
until recently those droughts have
always been spoken about with almost a
mythical type characters lead scientists
on research that use tree ring evidence
going back 1,200 years to study mega
droughts that lasted as long as 40 years
and the drought of the last 20 years has
developed the same way the mega droughts
did there is however one difference
between this long drought and the mega
droughts and trees ago and what we're
seeing today is a combination of natural
climate variability as well as human
caused climate change we would have a
drought even without climate change
climate change is making it a whole lot
worse so without human caused climate
change we'd still have a drought but it
wouldn't be as serious as the one that
we've actually seen
75% of the west's water supply begins as
snow you hit a big snowpack you hope
it'll fill up your reservoirs with
climate change it doesn't fill them up
nearly as much as it would up without
the warmer temperatures in the mountains
above Boise Idaho scientist hands Peter
Marshall is working to develop better
ways to determine how much water there
is in the snowpack so it's becoming more
challenging for us to not only predict
how much water is going to enter our
reservoirs but also the ability to store
that water all the way through the end
of the summer for agriculture and water
resource purposes Marshall is part of a
NASA project called Sno X developing
remote sensing equipment to get accurate
snowpack measurements from space so one
of the big pushes for us to develop a
spaceborne approach to monitoring snow
water resources is because these
patterns are changing so we're really
needing a approach that map's the amount
of water that's stored within the
snowpack over the past couple of decades
we've had a few years of droughts and
then we sometimes have record snow
record rain flooding it looks like the
drought is over the thing that's
changing now is that when we do have
those wet years when we do get a good
snowpack up in the mountains over the
winter we're seeing less water make it
into the rivers and downstream to the
farms in the cities and fish and
ecosystems that depend on that water
planning water use will become even more
crucial if indeed the West is in the
midst of a mega drought that could last
another 20 years or more for CBS this
morning Saturday John Blackstone San
Francisco another threat to our
well-being is both